30:28 from twentieth Century Fox and
blue sky studios
shooting stars Wow Wow my wish came true
mine too the defining chapter here
shower in the greatest chill achieve a
mother of all asteroids screaming
towards us but I've got a plan
boom with me crashing any reporting for
duty of all time all I wanted is true
love everybody has somebody and all I've
got is my boyish good looks is this Mary
a sheep in this silver the end of the
Ice Age
is just the beginning hey it sounds like
it's slowing down except for that one of
a new age here he is the master of
meditation the supreme serene the
shangri-la this is the guy who's gonna
save us yes but first down my dog huh
funky chicken melting very mashed potato
hey dude kind of easy could you help me
please
my nose is dangerously close to my but
I'll saij collision course
Hey look shooting stars Oh Oh quick
quick make a wish
make a wish you gotta make a Wow my wish
came true mine too
since the beginning of time we have
wondered how the universe came to be a
gloriously orchestrated plan or
something much much dumber
you're the wind beneath my fleas the
algae of my eye will you be my mate for
life
mmm I'm breaking up with you run and by
the way you look nothing like your
profile picture this year all I want is
true love is that too much to ask
Hey look shooting stars oh I want to
wish for the girl of my dreams
it sways just killing us shower meteor
shower 20th Century Fox presents
oh hello mammals but what are you doing
here it's just beginning a mother of all
asteroids screaming towards us we go to
a crash site search for clues and then
figure out how to stop it
who's with me crashing hey reporting for
duty
boy oh we look so cruel does that look
like a problem to you you're so pretty
who you talk with it Manny Ellie Sid
Diego buck and scratch do you mind
hurry granny don't you hurry me the you
pay ice age collision course sound like
it's slowing down yep it's definitely
over
except for that one
Hey look shooting stars Oh Oh quick
quick make a wish
make a wish you gotta make a wish Wow my
wish came true
mine too I think I've burned my
marshmallows